[Music]
the loud house shows exactly what it's
like to have a huge family but did you
know there were originally supposed to
be fifteen more sisters stay tuned to
find out the coolest sister that was
deleted from the loud house
are you the loudest loud house fan be
sure to subscribe for more awesome
videos now let's check out 10 missing
loud house sisters that didn't make it
in the show Beverly show creator Chris
Savino has revealed that the loud house
was originally supposed to be a show
about bunnies and Lincoln loud was
supposed to have 25 sisters we're so
glad that he only has ten sisters so we
can really get to know all about the
characters in the episode white hair we
can see what the show was originally
supposed to be like one of the bunny
sisters is Beverly Beverly is pretty
much exactly like Laurie except she
dresses in louann's colors yellow and
pink in the episode she tells Lincoln
who goes by Warren marine what girls
really want is a sensitive guy that
really seems like a great big sister but
we're happy with Laurie Blair white hair
is the 103rd episode of loud house so we
know the main characters really well by
this point it's easy to spot which
sisters were inspired by which rabbit
Lenny is definitely inspired by Blair
Blair is an older rabbit sister and
instead of white sunglasses she wears
pink she is extremely fashionable she
acts a lot like Lenny but she seems a
lot smarter
she doesn't do anything ditzy in the
episode she's really kind of a
one-dimensional character so we much
prefer Lenny with her head in the clouds
plus white sunglasses are so much more
stylish Blanche
with so many people in the loud house we
bet someone is always sick
can you imagine how awful it would be
for a virus to run through the family
we've got the loud spend a lot of money
at the doctor in white hair one rabbit
sister is always sick Blanche wears an
ice cap on her head maybe your headache
is just from having 25 siblings
she's also seen with a thermometer in
her mouth at all times the funniest part
is that she carries around allergy
test pads everywhere she goes we think a
sister like Blanche would have been a
funny addition to the loud family BB
Louann loud is one of everyone's
favorite loud sister she's hilarious to
everyone except her family BB is the
rabbit version of Luanne and the
animators really played up her comedic
personality BB is dressed like a clown
complete with the orange clown wig and a
bowler hat she has a squirting flower
pin to her shirt and even has a red
clown nose and just like the land none
of the other rabbit siblings find her
funny we loved that they really played
up her clownish character but we think
Luanne is much more believable you don't
have to be a literal clown to be
hilarious Brooke unlike BB Brooke
doesn't really have a human counterpart
and honestly a character like Brooke
might get kind of exhausting Brooke is
paranoid about everything she worries
about even the tiniest things sometimes
she even worries about germs and wears a
teal surgical mask
she's stylin though because her mask
totally matches her outfit and with his
sister like Blanche we can't blame her
for being worried about getting sick
Brooke worries about so much we think
she might have panic obeah that's the
fear of literally everything poor Brooke
we like Brooke for being totally
different than the usual loud sisters
Pippa mytha is one of the funniest of
the loud rabid sisters this rabbit loves
all things British she's obsessed with a
capital o she wears a very British blue
bowler hat and carries an umbrella
everywhere she even has it open indoors
this is she no that's bad luck like a
true Brit she loves tea she has a yellow
tea cup with her at all times she even
speaks with a British accent even though
none of her siblings do we know that
Lynne loud senior their human dad is
fascinated by British culture it's
totally possible that Lincoln's bunny
hallucination put this fascination on
one of the many sisters think she's
weird stay tuned for the craziest rabbit
sister breathe every family needs a chef
in the
rabbit version of the loud family the
chef is a sister instead of Lynn senior
Bree wears a chef's hat all the time she
even wears a typical chef's
double-breasted jacket Bree can whip up
any meal at any time even her name is a
food that's right Bree is a type of
fancy French cheese
YUM we wonder why none of the real loud
sisters inherited their dad's love of
cooking which sister would be the best
cook we think a sister like Bree would
have been a great addition to the loud
family okay are you feeling hungry or is
it just us Bodhi the human loud sisters
have lots of quirks and unique
personalities but the rabbit Bodhi might
be one of the core theists
Bodhi is a total hippie she wears a
flower headband that looks like it's
straight out of Woodstock or Coachella
she's always totally then nothing can
rile up her calm nature she's extremely
positive and tells Bella to realign her
chakras I think your chakras need some
lake in case you don't know chakras are
an idea from Eastern medicine that a lot
of new-age hippies are really into Bodhi
is definitely a creative character and
we think she would have been a fun
regular addition to the loud family
Betty Betty is the oldest repet sister
and she's basically an exaggerated
version of Laurie she's pretty much a
drill sergeant
in fact she's wearing the same military
inspired outfit that Laurie wears in the
episode no guts no glory
Betty is obsessed with bossing around
her two dozen younger siblings she yells
at them like they're at boot camp she
will force her siblings to make things
go her way
we're glad Laurie is not quite that
bossy but if we had 24 younger siblings
we might try the military approach too
we can't imagine the chaos of that many
sisters beulah there are a lot of crazy
unique sisters that were left out a loud
house but Beulah is definitely the
strangest Beulah is a total cowgirl
she wears cowgirl boots and a cowgirl
hat she even has her ears braided into a
ponytail she rocks a red bandana to
reminds us a little of Lan allowed
except way more Western she takes her
cowgirl drisana very seriously whenever
she chases someone she laughs those them
with her rope bula is hilarious but
we're glad that human Louds are more
believable relatable characters which
missing loud sister do you wish was a
regular character let us know in the
comments and that's it for the 10
missing loud sisters that didn't make it
into the show if you liked this video
give it a big thumbs up and don't forget
to subscribe to the things to see more
of the loud house
[Music]